وهم يقومون بعمل جيد أيضًا لأننا
سنبني حكومة قوية ومتماسكة معها
تفويض شعبي قوي يبقى فيه
تهمة لمدة 5 سنوات شئنا أم أبينا
اليسار
[موسيقى]
لم أصوت للديمقراطية بدونها
لا يزالون باختصار غير نهائي بالرغم من ذلك
يبدو لي أنه مما يخرج من
من التوقعات الأولى يمكن أن يقال ذلك
من قبل الإيطاليين في هذه الانتخابات
جاءت السياسات مؤشرا
كيارا والإشارة كيارا هو أ
حكومة يمين الوسط بقيادة الإخوان
في إيطاليا
[موسيقى]
هذا بالتأكيد لكثير من الناس
ليلة فخر وبالتأكيد أ
ليلة الفداء هي بالتأكيد واحدة
الليل نقول دموع عناق
أحلام الذكريات
[موسيقى]
سنقوم بمعارضة ستكون صعبة
وسيكون موقفا لا هوادة فيه هناك
سنفعل بكل قوتنا نحن
قادرة على معارضة لدينا بالفعل
تم القيام به في الماضي وسنفعل ذلك مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
اليوم هو يوم حزين لإيطاليا
أوروبا تنتظرنا ، نحن هنا
تم الضرب بكل الطرق لتجنبها
هذه النتيجة قاتلنا من أجل أنا
قيمنا وحاربنا معها
فكرة عن جنوب ايطاليا
[موسيقى]